August fascinates me I grew up in the
wine business where you did a lot of
business with Europe in the late 90s
early 2000s I was always confused by
August because August was the time that
I completely got in the zone because I
knew everybody was sleeping and what I
mean by that is everybody was on
vacation in Europe all my vendors they
were gone the whole month ghost in the
U.S a couple weeks here a couple weeks
there and you know it was really
interesting I just really used it as my
time to get ready for that fourth
quarter right August is the month this
is when people really slow it down look
for those out of office replies because
they're on the up during August and if
you're watching this video right now and
if you want it as bad as I hear you want
it and if this is your year and if this
is your moment and if you're sick and
tired and it's your time then my friends
you need to understand that these 30s
they're 30 or 31 these 31 I think 31
days hope that's right in August these
31 days in August is exactly when you
triple down